From now on, my son,
Yuki Urabe, will
join my daughter's righteousness.
[Music]
[Music] After he
gets well, he
says, ``I work at that diner over there.'' It seems like I've
seen it somewhere before.  A
fantasy world.
After all, this is the
life I've dreamed of in another world. All I've done this past month is
farm, take care of livestock, and
make sake. It's quite different from the life I had imagined in another world, but
maybe it's not as bad as I expected.
In this country, there
is a system called the amendment system, where people can take their own lives with support from the country.Why do these
people die?  That's
no good, so
sink into dark fear.I am your god.The
world's god activities that create religion and gods.Starting
broadcast in April 2023.There are
no believers in my lie.